now to the coronavirus in the middle of
all this don't forget there is a corona
virus pandemic still going on in the
rising number of cases and
hospitalizations in many areas are still
mounting at least nine states report
record increases in cases over the past
three days coronavirus hospitalizations
hit new highs in Texas that's for the
third day in a row as Omar Villafranca
reports from Dallas Texas governor Greg
Abbott says there is no need to scale
back three openings record high
coronavirus cases in Texas won't stop it
from opening what it calls phase three
restaurants can operate at 75% capacity
and the state played host to the first
PGA tournament in three months without
fans in attendance experts are concerned
about a lack of urgency in some
communities the virus is on its own
timeline and you know we may wish it was
over but it's not dr. Catherine Troy UC
is an epidemiologist at the University
of Texas School of Public Health she's
worried not enough Texans are practicing
physical distancing or wearing masks she
warns that without those precautions the
state's health system could be
overwhelmed we don't want to be in the
position of Italy where they had to make
some very hard decisions about medical
hospitalizations in Texas have climbed
more than 50 percent since Memorial Day
it's one of at least 14 states that have
seen recent spikes in hospitalizations
and at least 19 states reported
increases in their average new koba 19
cases compared to about two weeks ago
including Florida where new infections
in the state reached more than two
thousand on Saturday and Sunday and same
cases go up and seeing the positivity
rate also increased suggest that there
are outbreaks underway former FDA
Commissioner Scott Gottlieb says that
some of these outbreaks shouldn't be
surprising he states like Texas Florida
Georgia North Carolina South Carolina
will you see those outbreaks right now
never really reduced a number of cases
substantially they had spread it was
persistent and now it's flaring up in
New York City wants the epicenter of the
nation's outbreak thousands of
demonstrators poured
to Brooklyn to denounce racism and
support black transgender people but it
was this party like scene in Manhattan
over the weekend that has the governor
warning of closing parts of the city
again there is a very real possibility
that we would roll back the reopening in
those areas in Houston the numbers are
not good
hospitals are starting to fill up in the
county judge there says she may have to
recommend another stay at home order now
cases at Texas Medical Center in Houston
which is one of the world's largest
hospital complexes have risen an average
of three percent per day since Memorial
Day Anthony all right omar thank you